احنا كده اهو يا احمد مساء الخيرات شباب
استاذنك يا احمد
مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم ربنا يسعد
ليلتكم ان شاء الله
معلش ثواني اعمل الصوت
احنا بقى لنا فتره طويله انا نلتقي لسوء
حظي ولكن كانت في اسباب كثيره وان شاء
الله نحرص في المرات اللي جايه والاسابيع
اللي جايه باذن الله نكون لقاءاتنا اذا ما
كانتش هتبقى مصدر ازعاج لكم على فترات
اكثر باذن الله طبعا يا ريت تدعوكم
مقترحاتكم تحب نتقابل مثلا مره كل اسبوعين
مره كل شهر راح بين حتى مره كل اسبوع بكل
سهور انا عندي كم كبير من الاسئله بس قبل
ما يجي لي الاسئله جاءت لي اسئله اكثر
اخونا نور
الحرب العالميه الثالثه تدق والاسم فقط هو
من لا يسمعها ما راي سيادتك في هذا الشان
والله هو طبعا مفيش شك انه
ان احنا الان العالم كله بيعيش ازمه معهاش
منذ عام
1962 يعني من من وقت ازمه صواريخ كوبا وقت
ازمه صواريخ كوبا كامل في اقرب وقت اللي
اندلاع حرب نوويه بعد 60 سنه يعني احنا في
اقرب وقت برده الاندلاع صراع بين قوه
نوويه ولكن لحسن الحظ انه حتى الان
انه زي ما تم تجاوز ازمه اوبه بالحوار عبر
قنوات سريه ثم قنوات علنيه في ازمه كوبا
الان المؤشرات مؤخرا وهذا هو الخبر يعني
يدعو الى بعض الطمانينه اللي بقت في
مؤشرات على ان هناك اتصالات بين الولايات
المتحده وبين روسيا وبين قوى اوروبيه وبين
روسيا في محاوله على الاقل الاحتواء
الصراع بحيث ان لا يتطور الى صراع نووي
بين روسيا بين الغرب
مؤشرات كثير بيقولوا
همم ان احنا يعني لابد من التفاوض واحنا
لسه على الهواء احمد
تمام على بركه الله
فنموا الخير نقل نتمنى ان المساله ما
تكونش ابدا يعني حرب عالميه الثالثه
استاذنا لماذا لا يستطيع الجنوب اليمن
الانفصال برغم رغم برغم رغبه الشعب
الجنوبي في الانفصال وسيطرته على الارض
بشكل شبه كامل يعني هي مساله البلد او جزء
من بلد ينفصل عن بلد ثاني مساله بتتطلب
مجموعه من الامور منها رغبه ال- ال- اهالي
البلد طبعا اللي انت بتقوله معناها ان هي
رغبه كاسحه لكن ده اعتبار واحد لازم يكون
في توافق بين القوه اللي موجوده لانه ما
فيش بلد بيعيش في فراغ لازم تكون دول
الخليج لازم تقول القوه المؤثره في
الاقليم زي مثلا ايران زي مصر زي همم
الضوء كمان الدول الاوروبيه ال- ال- القوه
الكبرى الصين روسيا الامريكان دول لهم
قولوا مهم جدا لان هيكون في تداعيات على
اي قرار وبالتالي الاجابه المباشره ان حتى
هذه اللحظه لم يحدث هذا التوافق
وطبعا في امثله كثيره جدا يعني في التاريخ
على دول اراده ان هي تستقل وفشلت وفي دول
ثانيه استقلت وفشلت زي مثلا جنوب السودان
علشان كيف في المصلحه للقوه الكبرى في ان
هي تنفصل
الانسحاب من خرسانه هو هل هو تخطيط لشيء
كبير لا اعلم يا صديقي قصه الوضع على
الميدان الكلام فيه الحقيقه ما اعرفش
البعض يعني بيتكلم عنه لا اعلم اذا كان
عندهم معلومات ولا لا ولا هم بيستنتجوا
لكن لا علم له بين مباريات الامر اقصد لا
علمه ليه بالتفاصيل لكن ما اعلمه ان
الطرفين حتى الان الطرف الروسي والطرف
الاوكراني او الطرف الغربي ليس الطرف
الاوكراني عاجزين عن حسم الصراع بشكل سريع
الجانب الروسي طبعا عنده يعني المفروض ان
هو الطرف الاقوى عنده يعني قيود كثيره على
حركتها
من ضمن القيود ديت انه الطريقه الوحيده
اللي ممكن يستخدمها لحسم المساله هو تدمير
اوكرانيا بالكامل او تدمير المدن بالكامل
هذا امر صعب جدا صعب الاعتبارات كثيره
اللي اعتبرت انسانيه الاعتبارات سياسيه
لاعتبارات علاقات الروس بالاقران اعتبارات
كثيره يعني ده يسيء جدا لسمعه بلد بتقول
ان اوكرانيا جزء مني
الاسلحه اللي موجوده عند الروس اسلحه يمكن
ان تواجه بها قوه كبرى ما تطوروش اكتشفوا
ان عندهم عجز في بعض الاسلحه الصغيره
ومنها مثلا المسيارات
في حاجه على المستوى التكتيكي واضحه جدا
ان الروسي يرغبون او كانوا وما زالوا
يرغبون يعني في ان هم يحكموا سيطرتهم على
همم كل الساحل الجنوبي يسيطروا على
السواحل يسيطروا على الاجزاء الاربعه
ومنها خرسون اللي حضرتك بتقول عليه ولكن
واضح ده مخطط طويل لكن ايضا واضح ان ده
بياخذ وقتا طويلا جدا اكثر بكثير مما خطط
له الرؤوس والسبب طبعا التسليح الغربي ال-
همم الكبيره جدا
اسامه منور ربنا يخليك اسامه
تحدث عن منطقه الساحل الافريقي افغانستان
الجديده اه والله عندك حق تشبيه جيد اخونا
اللي هو 19 الى منطقه الساحل الافريقي لو
حضرتك ما تعرفش منطقه الساحل تخيل الدول
اللي هي موجوده جنوب موريتانيا والمغرب
والجزائر وليبيا هذه الدول بقت موبوئه
[موسيقى]
بالفوضى اولا يعني هي فيها كل الحقيقه
الاسباب اللي تؤدي الى افغانستان جديده
ايه الاسباب دي عندك الفقر عندك ضعف
الحكومات المركزيه عندك تدخل الدول الكبرى
عندك وجود قوى لان ما فيش دوله مركزيه
عندك يعني همم انقلابات عندك تمرضات عندك
الحركات المتطرفه جدا فطبعا هي منطقه فعلا
يعني احييك على الاسم اللي همم
ابدا افغانستان الجديده احمد الهاشم مساء
النور ربنا يخلي حضرتك في صوت تشويش ولا
لسه في صوت تشويش طيب معلش يا سلام حاضر
لو في مجال قلنا يا اخونا
هل تعتقد ان العداء بين ايران واسرائيل
حقيقي
ايوه اعتقد ان الاعداء بين اسرائيل وايران
حقيقي ومندهش جدا انه احد يعتقد انه اعداء
يعني فيك او مصنعه
يعني
وانا هضرب اكيد اكيد اكيد هو ده حقيقي ومش
عارف ليه همم هناك من يعتقد البعض بيعتقد
انه الايران اثناء الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه
توصلت مع الاسرائيليين او الاسرائيليين
تواصلوا معها والامريكان تواصلوا معها في
الفضيحه اللي عرفت لاحقا بايران جيت
القصه حقيقيه ولكن لما تيجي تشوف تفاصيلها
وتشوف الامثله المشابهه لدول بتتعامل من
تحت الطاوله مع اعدائها تجده انه عادي جدا
بس دي قصه الحقيقه وطول شرحها اذا كنت
بتسالني سؤال بسيط لان ده ممكن ياخذ الحلق
كلها فنعم هو اعداء حقيقي
اسرائيل تتمنى لو تختفي ايران من على وجه
الارض او يختفي نظامها بوضعيه الحالي
لماذا اصبحت الانتخابات الاسرائيليه موضع
اهتمام للعالم العربي اكثر من هذه قبل
والله انا منتهي»
او قبل سنه 2020 ما كانش في عدد الدول
اللي طبعت مع اسرائيل وبالتالي زي
الامارات وزي البحرين وزي المغرب وزي
الانفتاح
السوداني وطبعا بالاضافه طبعا للدول اللي
كانت على علاقه قبل كده باسرائيل زي همم
مصر والاردن وبالتالي التاسعه الدائره
الدول اللي عندها علاقات معلنا سياحه
وتجاره ويعني على كل المستويات وبالتالي
الاهتمام زاد على اعتبار ان بقى في تطبيق
انما يعني احنا كان زمان همم قبل عمليه
التطبيع
الكبيره ديت او الاتفاقات الابراهيميه
كانت دائما علاقتنا باسرائيل في اي
انتخابات نقول اذا جاء حزب العمل اذا جاء
حزب النقود اذا جاء تشكيل من اي من
الاحزاب الاسرائيليه كيف سي على القضايا
الفلسطينيه لكن السؤال المحوري السؤال ده
ترى موجود ولكنه على الهامش اما ولذلك ما
كانش كثير بيهتم بالانتخابات الاسرائيليه
لانه ثبت بالدليل انه مش فارق قوي حزب
العمال يجيء حسب العمل يجيء حزب النقود
يجي
الاختلاف ان واحد بيغتصب الارض باللهجه
حاده
وحزب العمل او اليسار برده بيواصل احتلال
الارض ولكن بطريقه ناعمه ولذلك ما كانش
كان في عزوف على الاهتمام بالانتخابات
الاسرائيليه لان النتيجه معروفه سلفا بقطع
النظر من يشغل السلطه يعني الان بقت في
مصالح اخرى يعني همم يعني مثلا اذا جاء
حزب شديد التطرف
اكثر من يهبل نتنياهو هيبقى محرج جدا
وجوده للامارات
ولبحرين وللمغرب ولاي دوله ممكن ان تفكر
لان دول اجندهم المعلنه طرد العرب عدم
الاعتراف باي اسرائيل غير يهودي الاعتراف
بكل المستوطنات وضم مزيد من المستوطنات
فيعني اعتقد هذا هو تفسير يعني
همم العداء بين الجزائر والمغرب متى ينتهي
يعني احنا طبعا في اكثر من الحلقه طالما
فيه همم تناقض في همم يعني بين الدولتين
والتناقد اي طبعا تاريخي همم يعني على
الاقل في تاريخهم الحديث الجمهوريه ملكيه
دوله التوجه غربي الى حد ما الدوله
شرقي الخلاف على قضيه الصحراء التنافس على
النفوذ تكافؤ القوى اعتقد انه ما فيش مؤشر
على تغير ال- همم المنافسه على الاقل زي
ما كانش العداء يعني
فيها كلمه المنافسه كلمه مهذبه هي الحقيقه
علاقتها سيئه انا بتكلم على الحكومات
لماذا اصبحت الانتخابات الان
السلام عليكم ايه رايك في القضيه الكرديه
ارجو ان لا نكون ضحيه مره اخرى وخاصه بين
الذين يتكلمون باسم الاسلام
التركي يعني انا اسف انه اقول لك انه انا
طبعا
قضيه الكرديه يوسف نقول اه يعني لانه يعني
ممكن يكون القرد يتم التضحيه بيهم فيه
يعني مش هيكون امر غريب كما حدث في
التاريخ ببساطه لانه الجماعات الكرديه
بتقدم نفسها
في مواجهه دول ايران تركيا سوريا العراق
ما عندهمش نفس الثقه لما يجي يتفاوضوا ثم
ان هم مشكلتهم مع دوله واحده يعني نفترض
مثلا انه كان الغرب كله والشرق كله اجتمع
على انه يدعمهم في مواجهه مثلا دوله
مركزيه ضعف وضعها زي سوريا المشكله مش في
الحكومه السوريه الا اوضاعها دلوقتي ليست
في احسن حال المشكله ان الثلاث حكومات
الثلاث دول الاخرى سوف تنتفض ايران وتركيا
والعراق
وما يحدث في سوريا اذا حدث يعني يعني ان
العدو يمكن ان تنتقل الى اراضيهم بسهوله
همم تحدث عن احتماليه ارتفاع الدولار
وافلاس مصر
همم ارتفاع الدولار هو خلاص ارتفع احنا
بنتكلم على حوالي 24 بيقترب من 24.5 فهو
مرتفع وارد طبعا مع انت عارف مع اي عمليه
تعوين بيحصل عمليه تعويم لاي عمله في بلد
بيعاني من شحف العمله ممكن يحصل
اوفرشوتينج يعني يضرب اكثر كثير ما
تتوقعات ده شفناه في اكثر من تجربه ثم لما
المصادر الدوليه بتتوفر بيهدا شويه
المتوقع انه يهدا قليلا بس يعني ده ده انت
لما بتجيء تتكلم عن سعر صرف
في اي بلد بتحط سيناريوهات يعني ايه يعني
مثلا اذا نجحت الحكومه اذا توفرت كل
العوامل اللي تمكنها من ان هي تكتبها
بعملات اجنبيه بان يكون في استثمارات
حقيقيه بان يكون فيه استثمارات ورقيه ناس
يجيء يشتروا الدور المصريه انه ناس تيجي
تتسلف ان الناس تتدم كل مصادر الدولار ان
العاملين بالخارج الاوضاع تتحسن في دول
اخرى فتتحسن اوضاعهم فيغسلوا السياح الى
اخرى بتحط السيناريوهات لكن الطبيعي
الطبيعي وفقا للمتاح انه من المتوقع ان
الدولار لا ينفلت اكثر من كده ودي برده
مساله عاوزه تضع مجموعه من السنهرات حكايه
الافلاس دي انا استبعدها ولما هو كلمت
حضراتكم عليها من حوالي شهرين ثلاثه احد
كتب لي انت همم
بتلطف في الامور لما تيجي عن مصر والله
ابدا انا بقول ما اعتقده اصل المساله مش
على انه مصر ولا مش مصر المساله على انك
تتكلم على بلد
في اكثر من 100 مليون في موقع حيوي جدا
مين ممكن من دول العالم يتحمل انه يترك
مصر تفلس مثلا ثم تفلس ليه ده انت في اسوا
الاحوال البلد عنده كل هذه الموجودات في
اسوا الاحوال يقدر انه يخصخص ويقدر يعمل
مشروعات للبيع ويقدر يعرض اصول فسيناريو
الافلاس
ااا سيناريو متشائم جدا استبعده
الان
ده اخونا ابو عبد الله بيقول الانسحاب من
50 لتربيها كيماوي لا اعلم يا ابو عبد
الله من قال لا اعلم فقد افتح لماذا اصبحت
هل تعتقد
سيد جوبيل انت لم تتحدث عن الصومال والله
عندك حق
انت عارف ان انا عندي حلقتين عن الصومال
عملتهم ثم همم يعني لم اذعهم لاسباب يعني
كتف وقتها كده لكن حاضر حاضر
بالمناسبه مش الصومال بس انا عندي على هذا
اللاب توب والله مش اقل مثلا من 15 حلقه
يعني رضيت فيهم اسابيع طويله جدا جدا في
اعدادهم اللي هي معظم الحلقات اللي انا
بتكلم عليها ولكن
للاسف انا شخص موسوس فجهز الحلقه واجهز كل
حاجه وبعدين
اتراجع اقول لسه شويه حلقه اللي هي
المثليه الجنسيه دي اخذت معي حوالي ست
شهور
يعني ان شاء الله بس طبعا السوبر ما
انطلقش علي كده الصومال كان ينطبق عليها
انه انا بابذل جهد في فهم الموقف الدولي
كله وبعدين همم تكون ذروه الاحداث تنتهت
وجاءت احداث ثانيه وهكذا لكن حاضر ان شاء
الله اخونا جرش همم ما رايك في عدم حضور
ملوكه امراء عرب لقمه الجزائر ده همم يعني
انت لو بتتابع القمم العربيه هتجد ان ده
شيء مقلوب جدا وهم الغياب عاده بيكون سببه
عدم الاتفاق على قضايا كواريه يعني مثلا
ايه هي القضايا الجوهريه الاول كانت
القضيه الفلسطينيه بعدين
ظهر لنا غزوه العراق مثلا الاردن ثم بقى
قرعه عندنا موضوعات كثيره مش محل اتفاق زي
اليمن وزي ليبيا وزي سوريا قضايا كثير وزي
القضيه
زي قضيه الصحراء قضيه كثير فبعد الزعماء
بيفضل انه لا يحضر لا يعني دائما في
العاده لانه هناك عدم اتفاق على قضايا جوه
السلام عليكم انا نزار من العراق كما كنا
محتاجين الى صوت موضعي ومحيط كصوتك ربنا
يخليك يا استاذ نزار ماذا يحدث لفرنسا
بافريقيا انا حاسس ان انا حاطط وشي في
الكاميرا هل الصوت واضح والصوره واضحه
ده اخونا احمد ماندو صديقكم هو اللي
بيساعدني في كل حاجه يعني ربنا يشكره يعني
مش عارف هو بيورطني بقى وانت ههه الصوره
كويسه
[موسيقى]
ههه
ماشي يا سيدي كثر خيرك هل تعتقد
خير شو رايك
خيي شو رايك بالوضع بسوريا والله الوضع في
سوريا كله على بعضه اكيد ملمسول وبيعلم من
السائل الوضع في سوريا ما هواش وضع عظيم
بس لو تحدد السؤال يبقى الاجابه اسهل لان
كده السؤال عام قوي الاجابه هتبقى عامه
جدا بس لو التحدد سؤال يا ريت
همم
ليش
لحظه معلش لحظه
ليش حضرتك بتحب ايران وبتبرر لها سلوكها
مع انه لازم تنصر اخوانك العرب خاصه
السوريين والعراقيين والايرانيين ما عم
يحموا نفودهم مثل ما حضرتك ايران عم تمزق
المجتمعات العرب يعني طبعا اخونا اس اس
بيقول انا بحب ارحم
وبامرر سلوكا احب اقرا ليه يعني لا انا
فارسي ولا انا اداري وحتى لو انا ما
بتكلمش ابدا على الدين انا مسلم سني يعني
فاحبها في ايه انا عمري ما زرت ايران عمري
ما اشتغلت في اي او ثلاث او اي حاجه لها
علاقه لايران انا عايش في بلد ما فيش
علاقات دبلوماسيه بينها وبين ايران لا
يعني هو القصه مش كده ولكن احنا عايشين في
اجواء الحقيقه على فكره هذا الموقف
بيكلفنا مش ما بيكلفنيش ايران يعني انا
شايف ان في بعض الزملاء اكل عيشهم بيقوم
فقط على سب ولا عن ايران كل يوم في كل
القنوات الكبيره اللي هي عندها تمويل ضخم
جدا
انا مش باحب ايران ولا باحب روسيا ولا
باحب البلد ما بتتحبش وتتكرعك الفكره
بمنتهى البساطه ان احنا بنتكلم على ايه في
ايران لما تيجي تقول لي ان في حكومه مثلا
يعني مصره على ان هي تضرب السيدات علشان
يصلوا ولا عشان يغطوا راسهم طب ما هو في
حد يعني ده كلام مقنع مثلا يعني طب ما انا
ممكن البس الحجاب كسيده وبعدين اعمل لكل
الموبقات هل ده يخليني اتعاطف معها لا
طبعا لما تقول لي ان في دوله مثلا بتفجر
ولا بتبعث ولا بتقتل الكلام لما بيكون على
ايران بيكون في اطار عام احنا معظم
القانون احنا معظم القضايا اللي بنتكلم
عليها ال- ال- الولايات المتحده الغرب بعد
الدول العربيه في حاله صراع مع ايران انا
باشرح هذا الصراع
لما بتشرح هذا الصراع بشكل موضعي بيبان في
وسط الاجواء اللي هي طول الوقت بتسب ايران
يعني ده انتصار لايران لا انتصر
الايرانيين ابدا لكن انا بفسر سلوك من
وجهه نظر يعني
ايران بتعمل كده ليه عندها مبرراتها زي ما
الدول الخليج زي ماء الولايات المتحده
عندها مبرراتها لكن لو بتتكلم على الصراع
الاساسي ايران في مواجهه الغرب بقياده
الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده فعلت
كل ما يمكن ان يستفز الايرانيين ويصادر
على حرياتهم وانقلب واجر واول انقلاب
عملته السي اي اي كان ضد رئيس منتخب في
ايران في الخمسينات
الايرانيين هم اللي شجعوا الشاه على كل
تجاوزاته وكل يعني همم
ضغطوا على الايرانيين الامر اللي شجع
التيارات متطرفه اللي هي الطيارات اللي
جاءت الى السلطه في سنه 79 يعني تاريخ
امريكا وحلفاءها مع ايران تاريخ اسود
يعني مش بالمعنى اللي وصل الي حضرتك
اما انت بتقول لي بقى بتقول لي سوريا
والعراق بيكرهوا ايران سوريا والعراق فيها
اطراف مختلفه بعضها طبعا بايدي بعضها
بيعارض على حسب مصالحه لكن المؤكد انه
ايران لما دخل في سوريا او داخله في
العراق لا يهم لها سوريا ولا يهمناها
العراق ولا يهمها اليمني همها الدفاع عن
مصالحها وهي وجودها في هذه الدول لتامين
مصالحها مش لمساعده العراقين ولا السوريين
ولا اليمنيين
رايك في الغاء اللغه الفرنسيه في المغرب
واستبدالها باللغه الانجليزيه يعني لم
اعلم بالموضوع فسامحني لا اعلم
لماذا لم يحدث انقلاب في ايران منذ الثوره
الاسلاميه لما بلد ما يحصلش فيها انقلاب
على السلطه معناها ان السلطه في نهايه
المطاف
بتحظى
بقدر من القبول في عدد كبير او في قطاع
كبير من المجتمع انا عارف ان الاجابه لا
لانها تستخدم القوه والقهر والظلم الكلام
ده نظريا ممكن تقول عليه اوكي بس هذا غير
صحيح لانه الشاه مثلا وجيشه
ومخابراته كانت بتستخدم نفس القارئ ثم
انقلب الشعب عليها الثورات بتحصل مهما
كانت قوه وبتش الدوله لكن لما يكون في
دوله
ما هو لو الشعب كله قام مش هيكون في اصلا
لا حرس الثوري ولا في سلطه ولا كذا ده
معناها ان ما زالت في قطاعات من الشعب
الايراني
ليست غاضبه بالقدر اللي يخلي الشعب كله
ينقلب على النظافه
لماذا تغدى الغرب عن احتلال روسيا للقرن
سابقا هو متى متى تغادر الغرب عن احتلال
روسيا للقرب تقصد بدايه من 2014
بس موضوع يعني 2014 دي كان لها ظروفها اذا
كنت بتتكلم على كده لانه القرن كانت
تاريخيا جزء من روسيا جزء من الاتحاد
السوفيتي وجزء من روسيا كان جزء من
الاتحاد السوفيتي ثم اعطيت لاوكرانيا على
اساس ان اوكرانيا الا في البيت بيتك يعني
العمليه واحده
واستقر تحت سيطرت اوكرانيا لكن روسيا قررت
استعادتها في 2014 او اعتبرها زي ما انت
عاوز السطو عليها اخذها في قصه يطول شرحها
واحنا عملنا قبل كده تكلمنا عنها بس ممكن
نتكلم عنها ثاني لكن رد على سؤال حضرتك
الغرب سلم به ان روسيا تاخذ
القرم في 2014 لانه ما كانش فيه مقاومه
بتذكر من سكان من لم يتم ازاله اي دماء
تمت المساله بمهنيه شديده تمت في ظروف
دوليه ما كانش للولايات المتحده ولا الغرب
مستعد للدخول في صراع من اجل اقليم معظم
سكانه من الروس
وده كان بعد كده خلاهم اكثر استعدادا
لمواجهه الروس لما ارادوا الدخول اوكرانيا
في هذا العام
عندك اجمل روح يا اخي ربنا يخليك شكرا
جزيلا لماذا
انا محتاج ان احنا نسال على المساله الغاء
اللغه الانجليزيه يعني لو عندكم معلومات
انا الحقيقيه ما اعرفش ده يعني الغاء يعني
الغيها كامل ولا اصبحوا يدرس انجليزيه يا
ريت تقولوا لنا يعني ايه مساله تسترع
الانتباه يعني انه يدرس اللغه الانجليزيه
هذا جيد لكن يلغي الفرنسيه
الى صراع منخفض الكثافه يعني اللي هو يعني
زي مثلا كان الصراحه في اوكرانيا في
فبراير ومارس وابريل شديد الحده وبعد كده
همم بيبتدي انه يبقى اسرع مزمن ما فيش كل
يوم قتله بشكل عنيف الاطراف بتتعايش مع
الصراع المجتمع الدولي بينصرف اهتمامه الى
اخره
هل هتبدا مصر في مشروع نهر الكونغو لم
اسمع عن المساله دي ابدا الان ومشروع نهر
الكونغو اكبر من امكانيات الاقتصاديه
لدوله واحده على الاقل في حدود الدوله
اللي بتتكلم عليها مصر ده عاوز مئات
المليارات ثم يريد دعم دوله كبير لانه ده
بيتجاوز حدود اكثر من دوله فمشروع يعني
مره حد قال لي كده الاسهل لمصر ان هي تجيب
ميه من المريخ على ان تاتي بماء من نهر
الكونغو على سبيل المبالغه يعني
ماذا تتوقع في مظاهرات ايران انا سيء في
التوقعات الحقيقه لانه انا 25 يناير مثلا
كان عندي توقعات ولقتها مشيت في اتجاه
ثاني 2013 كان عندي توقعات ومشيت في اتجاه
ثاني فانا مش جيد في التوقعات يعني ولكن
توقعي وقد اكون مخطئ انه انا بقول الكلام
ده من بدري يعني انه الايرانيين سوف
يتجاوزوا هذه المظاهرات هتبقى مظاهرات
بتتم لان كم يعني هتفضل موجوده لفتره الى
ان تثوي وتختفي وتضعف زي السترات الصفراء
وزي عشرات المظاهرات اللي شاهدتها ايران
في السنوات الماضيه
لو كانت المظاهرات دي قويه وبتشمل يعني
قطاعات مؤثره في ايران لا يعني تغير
النظام
شكرا جزيلا ربنا يخليك
بدا يحدث
المانيا وفرنسا كانت في اعداء تاريخي يعني
اللي هو لغايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه فيهم منافسه لكن
ما اعرفش ان في عداء وطبعا لما بيكون في
منافسه قوتين كبار القوتين الكبار دول
القوتين الرئيسيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
طبيعي ان يكون في اختلافات في وجهات النظر
لكن لا اعلم ان هناك اعداء بين الدولتين
ما رايك في الجزائر وانتظامها للبريكس على
فكره انا كنت كاتب الاسئله اللي حضراتكم
سالتموها لما طرحت الاسئله من حوالي 10
ايام وكان وقتها اكثر سؤال بيحضر باهتمام
حضرتكم البريكس فانا حبيت اسنبق الحلقه
ديت بحلقه على البركس نزلت امبارح
وتقدروا ترجعوا لها
وفيها تفاصيل كثيره يعني عن سبب تسابق
كثير من الدول لماذا تتصابك دول العالم
للانضمام لمنظمه البريكس لكن ردا على سؤال
حضرتك ما هو الجزائر تقدمت بطلب ولم تنضم
وكذلك ايران وكذلك الارجنتين وكذلك ترغب
السعوديه وتركيا ومصر وفي دول ثانيه في
الطريق اما انه البريكس مهتم به او هي
مهتمه به بريكس طبعا لو بعض اصدقاءنا ما
يعرفوش يعني ايه البريكس انا بنتكلم على
المنظمه اللي هي بتضم خمس دول الصين
وروسيا والهند والبرازيل وجنوب افريقيا
ومؤخرا هذا التكتل اللي اسمه بريكس لانه
اخذ الحروف الاولى من الخمس دول بيسعى لضم
دول جديده عاده هو بيختار دول من ال- مش
عاده هو بيختار دول من الاسواق او الدول
الناشئه او الناميه لنيجي فكره البريكس
اللي هي الدول الناميه بتتكتل في مواجهه
القوه الكبرى اللي بتاخذها امريكا واللي
اهم منظماتها مجموعه السبع الصناعيه
الكبرى
فبديه ان الجزائر الجزائر عندها امكانيات
كبيره ولو حصلت عمليه تحديث الاقتصادها
وسوء مال وفتحت على العالم هتبقى قوه
كبيره طبعا وهتبقى اضافه خصوصا ان هي قوه
كبيره في الطاقه يعني
ما رايك بفكره اتحاد الدول الخليجيه كدوله
واحده مستقبلا يعني الكلام سهل لكن هذا لم
يحدث
هذا يصعب ان يحدث هذا على الارجح لن يحدث
ما رايك في حركات التنوير ده
اخونا بيجيسوس ما رايك في حركات التنوير
في العالم العربي وهل اعتقد انه لابد من
فرد العلمانيه قصرا على الشعوب بعد تعرضها
لسنوات من ادلج الطيارات الاسلام السياسي
طب انت مين اللي هيفرض العولمه اذا كانت
انت بتقول انه يعني تفرضها يعني الناس مش
عاوزاها
لا هي القصه انه يعني
حركات التمويه في العالم العربي كلمه طبعا
مفتوحه لكن انا بستنتج من كلامك ان
التغيير يعني اللي هي الحركات اللي بتدعو
لتحديث المجتمعات وانه تبقى فيها دوله
قانون وان تبقى علمانيه بمعنى انه
اييي ان الدوله ما يكونش ليها دين محدد
ولكن تحترم كل الاديان وانه الدوله تقف
على مسافه واحده من كل الاديات ولكل يبقى
حريه العباده في محميه ده اللي هو موجود
مثلا في دول زي فرنسا زي بريطانيا زي زي
دول كتير زي المانيا ولكن ده تطور حدث بعد
قرون من التطور وبالتالي الكلام ده ما
حصلش النهار ده ده بيتطور على مدار قرون
اذا ده حصل في العالم العربي هيحصل بعد
فتره طويله جدا
لماذا الغرب ده اخويا عبد الله لماذا
الغرب يحارب الدوله الدينيه مثل السعوديه
وايران مثلا السعوديه تغيرت مثلا من دوله
وهابيه متشدده الى دوله شبه علمانيه الان
وذلك الوضع في ايران
انت لو قلت من السعوديه هم بيزعلوا اصلا
من الكلمه
ده ينطبق على ايران
الغربي بيحاربها العالم كله بيحاربها مش
مش الغربي بس لان اصل انت حكايه تقول دوله
افغانستان ولا زي ايران بس ايران رغم ان
هي دوله دينيه بيحكمها مرشد بس قادره تجمع
ما بين انه دوله دينيه بيحكمها الولي
الفقيه وفي نفس الوقت بنجماتيه جدا انه
احيانا يعني ايه زي ما انت شفت كده كان في
ازمه اثناء الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه اوكي
همم نتعامل مع الامريكان نتعامل مع
اسرائيل لا ممكن ننفتح على دول ثانيه ممكن
نقيم علاقات مع يا مع الاتحاد السوفيتي
بعد هي يعني عدت شويه لكن اهي نرجع ثاني
في نظرك ما هو نصير النزاع بين الجزائر
والمغرب حول الصحراء بصراحه يا رضوان
اعتقد انه المغرب هيقدر ينجح الى حد كبير
في فرض تصوره لانه قدر يعمل سلوري باتشور
له امر واقع يعني بيقول للناس
ايه البديل يعني كلهم
البديل اللي بيقولوه الصحراويين وطبعا ده
حقهم بيقولوا احنا عاوزين استفتاء وعاوزين
دوله مستقله المغرب واخذ دي ارضي انا هنا
مش باتكلم على وجهه نظر المختلفه الناس
عارفه الكلام ده بس اصل دول ان المغرب
موجود على معظم الارض على حوالي 80% من
الارض ومعاه دعم دوله ايه ومعاه القوه
وبعدين بيقدم عرض برده ممكن يغري بعض
الصحراويين يقول لهم تعالوا خليكم اقليم
ضمن المغرب ويبقى همم
خذ حكم ذاتي في
تخيلي انه المغرب على مدار سنوات الناجح
بالاضافه ان في عوامل ثانيه انه يقول ان
وجهه نظري وجهه نظر معقوله يمكن تطبيقا
وقبل ما تجيلي عشرات الرسائل يقولوا لي
بقى انت بتاخذ تمويل من المغرب والله
العظيم انا باقول الاجابه اللي اعتقد انها
يعني انت بتقول لي ممكن يحصل ايه يعني ده
اللي انا بقوله الصح بالمناسبه حكايه
الصحه والغداء عشان حد بيقول لي ايه قول
رايك اقول رايي في ايه يعني القضيه دي مش
انت بتسالني مثلا على قضيه فيها راي انت
بتسالني على خلاف ما بين دولتين نفترض انه
كلمه الراي ديت يعني ايه اللي عاجبني يعني
لا انا باقول انه كل دوله عندها تصور ايه
لو نفترض ان المساله دي مفتوحه للاراء لو
مفتوحه للاراء ما الاراء ما تم- هو معروف
تم المغاربه كلهم رايي والجزائر كلهم رايي
فايه اللي هيضيفه ان احد يقول رايه انت
بتبسط الحقائق وتقول المغرب بيفكر ازاي
الجزائر بتفكر ازاي الصحراويين بيفكروا
ذلك انت بتسالني ممكن يقول الى ايه الاقرب
للمنطق انه المغرب تفرض رؤيتها وده هيفضل
مصدر توتر بينها وبين الجزائريين وطبعا
الصحراويين
رايك في المظاهرات ضد السيسي التي سوف
تكون في مصر 11/11 يعني رئيس ايه يعني
المظاهرات والاحتجاجات في اماكن كثيره في
العالم وبالتالي ليس له راي محدد يعني
ننتظر تفصيل عميق للاقتصاد الروسي على
قناه نعرف اقتصاد والله انا شايف انه
القناه يعني مش همم بشكل جيد الحمد لله
والناس متقبلاها بشكل كويس بس هو احنا
بنحاول نوفق بين حاجتين
فكره انه الحلقات تكون قصيره زي ما بيطلب
لبعض بس عشان تكون قصيره يعني المفاهيم مش
هتتشارح بشكل كافي علشان تتشرح بشكل كاف
وتكون ميسره لازم الحلقات هتكون اطول لكن
على العموم هنحاول نجد اكثر من حل وزي ما
قلت لحضراتكم ما فيش طريقه سحريه ان انت
تفهم علمه مستغلق عليك غير ببعض الصبر
الصبر الاستماع فقط
الامور تبقى احسن
هل تتوقع حرب اهليه في امريكا الامريكان
هم اللي بيتوقعوا حرب احليه انا مش متوقع
بس الامريكان وبعدين كان في بوادر اللي هي
سته يناير 21 طبعا دي كانت سابقه خطيره في
امريكا اللي هي اقتحام مبنى الكونجرس
وبالتالي بعض الامريكان
بيتوقع انه تبقى في حرب اهليه والامريكان
او امريكا ما هياش غريبه على فكره الحروب
الاهليه يعني
والله ممكن هينفع موضوع يعني
هل بامكان ان تتحول الدوله الجمهوريه الى
ملكيه والحصلت تاريخيا خلاف بريطانيا ان
دوله تتحول الى ملكيه الدوله
عشان تتحول الى ملكيه لازم يكون في اسره
ملكيه ترجع الملكيه ثاني تقصد لان انا
جمهوريه اجيب ملك منين يعني الملكيه
بتتحول لجمهوريه لان في اسره ملكيه بتحكم
وبعدين الشعب اراد ان يغير العكس بقى
معناها ان كانت هي ملكيه وبعدين ارادوا
اعاده الملك مره اخرى انت عاوز دوله ايه
اللي تبقى ملكيه
هل تعتقد ان سبب نجاحك هو غياب تملي اعلام
عربي موضوعي ومحايد يعني ربنا يخليك لو
بتعتبر الناجح اشكرك بس لو عاوز اقول
اجابه يعني تجاوزني انا في الخلفيه
وبنتكلم في المطلق انا السؤال اللي بتطرحه
ده اللي هو فكره ايه اللي بيخلي يعني بعض
القنوات تنجح
انا عندي يقين انه في فقر عنيف جدا في
المحتوى باللغه العربيه
سواء من اول الطبخ
يعني الحاجات اللي هي الطبخ
الحاجات الانترتين من اي حاجه اي حاجه من
اول ازاي تلبس رابطه العنق ومش عارف ايه
كل الحاجات دي موجوده في لغات اخرى باللغه
الانجليزيه الفرنسيه الصيني المحتوى مش
موجود باللغه العربيه والمحتوى اللي موجود
باللغه العربيه بسيط وفقير وبصراحه في بعض
الاحيان بيكون سطحي الى حد مخجل
وبالتالي اضف دائره كده انه الاعلام اللي
موجود اللي انت بتتكلم عليه يبقى يتناول
الشان الاقتصادي والسياسي الحقيقه اعلام
مخجل لانه مصر على الاستقطاب بشكل عنيف
احيانا بدون مبرر يعني اعلام موجود في
دوله ما مش محتاج ابدا ابدا يعني انه يخبي
حقائق العالم كله عارفها والشعب عارفها
اعلان فقير انت بتفتح على قنوات بعض
القنوات العربيه تشعر كانه لا يوجد حدث في
العالم الا ايران وبتفتح قنوات اخرى مثلا
تجد انه كان ما فيش مشكله غير القضيه اللي
شغلاهم يعني مسلطين عليها ضوء ليل ونهار
وبالتالي طبعا اعلام استقبل اعلام يقوم
على الاخفاء التزييف والاخطر من كده عدم
البدل الجهد قضيه موجوده محتاج تنزل مجهود
علشان تفهمها فانا بادله جهد لفهم القضيه
الماء ولا في نفس الوقت في نوع من
رغبه في مناقشه القضايا الحقيقيه اللي
بتشغل الناس في رغبه بس انه يفرض او يغذي
الناس بوجهه نظر وبالتالي اي قناه اي قناه
هتحاول تبذل جهد وتحاول تبقى موضوعيه
هيكون لها نصيب ان شاء الله من النجاح
سيد جبيل لماذا الغربي جاوبناها ننتظر
تفصيل عميق للاقتصاد الروسي حاضر ان شاء
الله والاقتصاد التركي والاقتصاد المصري
على فكره انا في اسئله جاءت لي كثير عن
الاقتصاد المصري بس استاذنكم انا عملت
قناه نعرف علشان نتكلم عليها فاللي
بيسالني لان في عدد كثير جاي من الاسئله
عن الاقتصاد المصري
والسبب ما زي ما دائما باقول لكم المصريين
بنشطه حين همم
تطرح مساله الاقتصاد المصري لكن الاقتصاد
المصري الاقتصاد التركي
الاقتصاد المغربي الاقتصاد لا يعني فيه
سلسله حلقات جايه ان شاء الله هيكون فيها
البرازيلي
انا بتكلم على الحلقات اللي هي موجوده
يعني مخطط لها
ننتظر تفصيل
رايك في تاني لماذا تراجعت مصر عن دعم
روسيا والحلف الشرقي لمعادله توازن القوه
في مصلحتنا عن طريق سعي امريكا الى الضغط
على القاده للحضور في مصر مقابل التراجع
عن دعم روسيا انا مش فاهم السؤال قوي بس
اللي انا فاهمه ان انت بتقول مصر تراجعت
عن دعم روسيا اكيد في القضيه الاخيره
ومصر والله حاجه بالمناسبه يعني انت
بتتكلم من الحاجه اللي بتسترع الانتباه
وتستحق الاحترام ان الدول العربيه في
القضيه ديت ما بتكلمش عن مصر بس بتكلم من
اطراف الخليج يعني دول الخليج وخد كده
امشي امشي طبعا لان لها وضع خاص يعني دوله
اقصى طرف هتلاقي ان الدول ديت اخذت موقف
يعني ناضج جدا
خلصتوا كده لا يعني انا لا روسيا ولا
امريكا احنا برواز المصلحتنا مع الروس مع
الامريكان الصينيين ومش هنقف في معسكر اتز
نوت اورفايد دي مش حربنا ف- اا تقدر تقول
انه دول العربيه قدرت ان هي تلعب اوراقها
بشكل جيد وبشكل كويس بحيث بحيث ما تخسرش
هذه القوه الكبرى وده افضل موقف كانت ممكن
تاخده في حال انضم في حال انضمت السعوديه
للبريكس هل تتوقع ان تنحدر العلاقات بينها
وبين واشنطن وكيف سترد الاخير على هذا
الامر العلاقات بين لا تنحدر لمجرد
انضمامها للبركس هيكون هيؤدي الى همم
تدهور اكثر في العلاقه بين السعوديه
وامريكا لكن مش قطيعه يعني
اصل امريكا اصلا وقع في مشكله ما هي اقرب
حلفائها بما فيها اسرائيل انضم مثلا
مبادره الحزام والطريق ال ال ال ال ال
الصينيه فمن المساله مش هتبقى واقفه على
السعوديه بس هتتكلم على السعوديه بتتكلم
على مصر بتتكلم على تركيا تركيا في تحالف
مع الولايات المتحده لانها جزء من حلف
شمال الاطلسي تتكلم على الامارات
فرق التسعه على الرائق زي ما بيقولوا لانه
في مرحله تحول احنا في مرحله تحول مرحله
التحول دي الجديد على اساسا في واشنطن
دلوقت لانه منذ سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي
وقابليه شويه ما فيش احد قادر ينافس
الولايات المتحده دلوقت انت عندك الصين
لوحدها قوه كبيره لما ينضم اليها الروس
لما تقدر ان هي تجمع حواليها مجموعه من
الدول زي الدول البريكس او مجموعه من
الحلفاء الاخرين ومش لازم الحلف يكون
يعني
اكسبلوسف يعني يبقى علينا بس قاصر ده
انكنوسف يعني يقول لك اهلا وسهلا هاتوا
دول تانيه
لا هيادي الى تدهور يعني هيؤدي الى مزيد
من عدم الثقه
في قلوب الامريكان تجاه السعوديه والعلاقه
مع السعوديه بالمناسبه اخيره في منحدر
فاتدر منذ احداث 11 سبتمبر وان شاء الله
نعمل حلقه على السعوديه
وامريكا لانه دي علاقه قصه مثيره للخضول
مرت بمراحل بعضها سري وبعضها لكنها همم
موضوع يستحق ان احنا نركز عليه
بمناسبه السعوديه في صديق كان يعني قال لي
انت بتتكلم على
السعوديه اكثر من دول الخليج الاخرى ايه
المساله مش انا يعني على حسب الاحداث يعني
القناه دي طلعت تقريبا في اول 2016 يعني
في ذروه احداث الربيع العربي كانت مين
الدول المؤثره في الاحداث مصر كانت موقفه
على نفسها عشان خارجه من كل احداث 2011
و2013
سوريا كانت ضربت بشده العراق ما كانش
تعافى حتى الان وبالتالي القصه الدول اللي
هي مين الدول اللي كانت واخده الاحداث
هتلاقي قطر هتلاقي الامارات هتلاقي
السعوديه هتلاقي الدول اللي حاطط وطبعا
بحكم النسبي كانت السعوديه بتحضر
بالاهتمام الاكبر
وفي سبب ملوش علاقه معرفش صوت بس انه انا
وجدت ان العدد الاكبر ده ارقامي يوتيوب
بتقول لي جاي من السعوديه دي حاجه انا
اتشرف بيها بس انا ما تدخلتش فيها اهلا
وسهلا بالناس من اي بلد بس نتيجه ان يكون
في عدد كبير من متابعين بلد معين بتبقى
اسئلههم بتخلي اجنده القناه او دائما
بتعبر عن شويه غيرهم
همم ماذا سيحدث لبوتين وروسيا اذا خسرت
الحرب في اوكرانيا روسيا
يعني الاول ده الاجابه عليه سهله جدا يبقى
خلاص انتهى سياسيه يعني خساره الروس في
قطن هي نهايه قطن
انما روسيا بقى موقفها يكون ايه ده يتوقف
على نهايه الحرب تقصد ايه بالخساره لكن
مفيش شك ان هي يعني لن تخرج الى خسره
الحرب لم تخرج سليمه تماما وتتاثر بشده مش
بس نتيجه يعني قوتها وشكلها قدام اعدائها
وخصومها في الغرب ولكن حتى موقفها بالنسبه
لحلفاء هذه الصين الصين مهتمه بيها لانها
قوه كبيره اذا بدت وانها نمر من وراء طبعا
هتفقد كثير من اهميتها حتى لاصدقائها
رؤيتك لمستقبل الصراع في بحر الصين الصراع
في بحر الصين
والصراع على تايوان هيكون نقطه مفصليه في
شكل هذا العالم ما ان تسيطر الصين على
تايوان سوف تحكم
سيطرتها على بحر الصين الجنوبي هات
الخريطه وشوف طيران فين هتسيطر على تايوان
يبقى تقدر بسهوله تبصب سيطرتها على جنوب
على بحر الصين الجنوبي اذا سيطرت على بحر
الصين الجنوبي اول حاجه هتعملها تطرد
القوات الامريكيه من هذه المنطقه اذا خرجت
القوات الامريكيه من هذه المنطقه الصين
سوف تصبح ليس فقط القوه الكبرى في اسيا
ولكنها سوف تصبح القوه العظمى في هذا
العالم
ننتظر
رؤيتك لمستقبل مساله الغاء
مساله الغاء اللغه الفرنسيه
وليس اختيارا استراتيجيا والله ده حد
بيدينا اجابه انا الحقيقه ابحث في المساله
وشكرا لان انت اديتني فكره بشكل اكبر بعد
الحلقه يعني واتواصل مع اصدقائي في المغرب
في نظرك همم
لماذا تراجعت مصر عن لبنان في حاله انضمت
السعوديه
ما رايك في الانتاج الانتقالات الموجهه
لتنظيم قطر لكاس العالم والله كثير منها
بصراحه انتقادات ظالمه يعني وانتقدت مغرضه
لانه كاس العالم بزنس والناس طمعانه في
هذا البزنس لكن غير انها منافسه اقتصاديه
هي كمان فيها نوع من الاستعلاء يعني يعني
بلد زي بريطانيا مش قادر اتخيل ان انا مش
قادر اخذ كاس العالم وقطر تاخذه
فطبعا بعض الانتقالات لما بيقولوها
انتقادات وجيهها يعني بس الانتقادات دي
تنطبق على دول ثانيه يعني يقول لك مثلا ان
العمال اللي موجودين في قطر بيعاملوا
معامله سيئه جدا طيب ده ده صح في دي امر
سيء جدا ان انا طب يعني بريطانيا ولا
الدول الاوروبيه بيعملوه ايه في المهاجرين
وهل لان الدوله بتعامل المهاجرين المعامله
همم ده يجعلها غير حاله ان هي تستضيف كاس
العالم يبقى ما فيش ولا دوله هتبقى قادره
على استضافه كاس العالم الا اذا كانت دوله
افلاطونيه يعني
هذا ما اعلم به يعني انا ده حدود
الانتقادات اللي قراتها لو في انتقادات
ثانيه انا لست على درايا بها اكتبوا
لماذا تراجعت وفي اخونا مصر اكرم ابراهيم
والله انا شفت اكرم انت بتسال على
المظاهرات في 11/11 والله هو ده رايي انا
ما عنديش حاجه اخفيه يعني في دعوه
للمظاهرات الدعوه دي كانت موجوده قبل كده
وقبل كده وهتبقى موجوده بعد كده فا
نا مش في ايه يعني في ناس عندهم موقف
شايفين ان الاوضاع سيئه وعايزين يحتاجوا
عليها ده حقهم يعني ما فيش فيها همم يعني
همم يعني يعني مساله واضحه ما فيش فيها
حاجه يعني لماذا تراجعت مصر
في حاله انضمت السعوديه
طب انت ايه رايك يا اكرم انت يعني انت
عاوز تشوف انت عاوز تقول ايه واحنا بنقول
والله ما فيش مشكله يعني
توقعاتك عن مستقبل الاسد في سوريا هي
مشكله الاسد او الرئيس الاسد يعني
في سوريا
يعني اللي هو بيكون رئيس بالضروره يعني
ايه يعني نفترض ان في اجماع من السوريين
ان الرئيس الاسد وانا يعني لو جهاز لي ان
انا اقول انا مش سوري انه الافضل يقول
كفايه كده وسوف اترك المكان الى غيره طبعا
دي مساله صعبه جدا وتبقى عمليه يعني
مثاليه جدا لانه اي رئيس او سياسه لما
بيدخل السلطه في الدول الناميه
وافترض فيه عفه اليد لكن هو بحكمه ممارسه
السياسه ومواجهه خصوم كثيره بيتور في كثير
من القضايا والصراعات اللي مستحيل يخرج
منها في السلطه ويجلس هادئا في بيته هيتم
ملاحقته ده في اقل الاحوال لانه ممكن يفقد
حياته وبالتالي
فكره توفير ال ال ال
المخرج الامن ديت ضروريه جدا لاي دوله
عاوزها يكون في تداول سلطه في الدول
الاعمده لانه تحط نفسك مكانه انا بقول
بفترض فيه سلامه النيه اما اذا كان هو
متورط فعلا في جرائم وفي كذا دي قصه ثانيه
لكن انا باخذ السيناريو اسهل ان هو دخل
السلطه وكان راغب انه يكون عفيف في اليد
وانه يكون كل الكلام بس بطبيعه الامور
المسائل مش ابيض واسود لان ده مش بيستغل
تلف في بنك فانا النهارده بدل الناس
مرتباتها ولا مدخراتهم نرى رئيس دوله
بيواجه اقليات وبيجه همم قوميات مختلفه
وبواجهها ثورات وانتفادات وصراعات على
السلطه فلازم هيكون في عشرات الملفات التي
يمكن ان يطارد بها الى خرج من السلطه
فصعبه وعموما ده لو اراءات اما اذا لم يرد
فبرده بيبقى في مشكله في الدوله انه نتيجه
ركود على مدار سنين بيكون البدائل تقريبا
مش مطروح
وبالتالي الرئيس الاسد في الوقت الحالي
يعني ما يعني ما فيش هناك مثلا ما فيش
مجموعه مثلا همم بيتو نفسه علشان نقول
الرئيس الاسد او مين يعني وباقي الى ان
يكون يعني لله مشيئه اخرى
همم
لماذا لا تخضع اسرائيل لرقابه الطاقه
الذريه وما يمنع ايران ان تخرج من هذه
الاتفاقات مثل كوريا الشماليه ما هو اولا
بالنسبه اسرائيل لا تخضع لرقابه الطاقه
الذريه لانها لم توقع عليه اتفاقيه منع
انتشار السلاح النووي الاتفاقيه ديت بدات
في سنه 70 يعني على ما اذكر
وكانت عمليه اختياريه انت عاوز توقع يعني
تلتزم بعدم انتشار السلاح النووي اهلا
وسهلا اذا وقعت هتستفيد بان احنا هنساعدك
في تطوير قدراتك النوويه السلميه ده واحد
افتح قوسين الى ملتزمتش هنفرض عليك عقوبات
هائله الدول الكبيره امريكا
وفرنسا وبالمناسبه روسيا بالصين مش
هيسمعوا يعني الدول جوارهم ان هي يبقى
عندها سلاح نووي يعني بس دائما الكلام على
المجتمع الغربي في اسرائيل
طبعا ده حاجه فاني حاجه تضحك لكن هذا هو
الوضع ان انت بتوقعش فانت اوكي يبقى اصل
طول ما تعاقبوش يعني
يعني مثلا لما العراق حاول يطور سلاح نووي
عقبه بشكل قانون او بشكل غير قانوني
لانه قالوا انت موقع طب لو كان العراق
انسحب مثلا كان خلاص المسائل انتهت ابدا
طب ما كوريا كانت موجوده
اسرائيلي لها وضع
استثنائي في التاريخ
ما الذي يمنع ايران ايران لو خرجت من
الاتفاقيه النوويه ممكن بس يعني في الحاله
ديت يبقى هي هتتعرض لمزيد ومزيد ومزيد من
العقوبات الدوليه على كل الصعد وبعدين هي
خلاص هي بقت عندها القدره ان هي تملك
القنبله مستنيه يعني هي عملتها بشكل صعب
انه يتكرر ثاني في حفله من الزمن انت
بتقول ان انا والله انا باقول لك اهو هم
عملوا فعلا اخرى فيه قدروا ان هم يديروا
اوراقهم بشكل جيد النتيجه انه على مدار
سنين اصبح لديه القدره على تصنيع السلاح
النووي والقدره على تصنيع الصواريخ
القادره على حمل السلاح النووي دلوقت في
اي لحظه قرر انه
يصنع القنبله مش هياخد كثير هياخد وقت
قليل جدا وبالتالي وقتها يكون عنده رادع
نووي بس طبعا الرد على النووي ده يحميك من
الغزو يحميك من الضرب لكن لا يحميك من
العقوبات الاقتصاديه الهائله وباكستان
دوله نوويه وعندها يعني مئات من الرؤوس
النوويه ولكنها مضطر ان هي تموت بيدها الى
حلفائها لانه النووي يحميك من الغزو لكن
لا يحميك من العوز والفقر
كيف يمكن لدوله ضعيفه مثل سوريا والعراق
والامن ولبنان وغيرها الكثير لا يحدث فيها
تغيرات جذريه مثل الانقلاب او ثوره او اي
تغير كبير بالرغم من ضعفها ما هي الدوله
المركزيه ضعيفه ولكن ال- ال- في تشرد يعني
في تكافؤ قوه يعني انت عندك في ايران مثلا
ان عندك همم
الصدريين والتنسيقيين فانت بتتكلم ده على
سبيل المثال يعني دي قوه فيها نوع من
التكافل فمينها ينقلب على مين زي ما في
همم لبنان حزب الله يملك القوه العسكريه
الاكبر لكن مش القوه اللي تمكين ومن
اريحكم من لبنان لانه في قوه اخرى
يعني تمنعه من هذا فتكافؤ القوه ايه اللي
بيمنع مثلا لقدر الله ان يحصل حرب ما بين
الجزائر والمغرب تكافؤ القوى
كيف تكون هناك حريات في فرنسا وهو وهناك
الكثير من المساجد تم اغلاقها وما فيش
يعني ما فيش دوله افلاطونيه كده
في كل دوله فيها تعصب وفيها عنصريه وفيها
تلاعب بالقوانين وفيها رشا وفيها فيها كل
حاجه بس لما الناس بيقولوا ان في حوريه في
فرنسا قارب ما يحدث في فرنسا وفي بريطانيا
وفي المانيا من قدره الناس على الاحتماء
بالقانون وقارنها بدول اخرى المواطن مش
امن ان روح من بيته من شغله الى بيته انه
يرجع سالم لاي سبب من الاسباب لانه ممكن
ضابط شرطه صغير يعني يحاول حياته الى جحيم
في دوله قانون في الشك وتقدر تحمل ده يعني
هل تتخيل ان في فرنسا مثلا ودي مش حاجه
جيده مكرون من اقل من سنه وهو بيوصف في
الناس واحد مد يده وضربوا بالقلم
تتخيل في فرنسا قالوا دي عقوبتها ان واحد
اعتدى على موظف عام ممكن ياخذ فيها 6 شهور
سجن تخيل انت مثلا واحد ضرب رئيس دوله
وعدوان بدون مبرر يعني اهانه بالغه وعلى
الكاميرات فيقولوا له والله القانون عندنا
بيقول ده موظف عام هياخد ست شهور ممكن
تخيل ده ممكن يحصل في ايه لو كان في دوله
ما فيش فيها القانون قوي بهذا الشكل
ثم ان الدول دي عاوزه تترحل ناس كثيره حتى
مهاجرين غير شرعيين واحيانا القانون
بيمنعها
ما هو سر عداء ايران وحزب الله والاسلام
الشيعي الاسرائيل وهل هو حقيقي مش الاسلام
الشيعي المساله مش ان هم شيعه ولا سنه ولا
مسيحيين ولا هم يهود بالنسبه لي
حزب الله ده حركه قامت في الاساس في اوائل
الثمانينات على مراهده الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وتحرير لبنان
وحظيت بدعم من ايران اللي كانت لسه قايمه
فيها الثوره الاسلاميه سنه 79 في ايران او
النخبه اللي كانت حاكمه ووجدت انه في عداء
اسرائيل اولا هي عقيده وايمان وكل شيء اضف
الى كده انه بيعزز مصالحها السياسيه وهو
بيعطيها نفوذ ااه اكبر بكثير جدا من ان هي
لو ما كانش عندها حسبي الله ما لهاش علاقه
بالاسلام الشيعه او غير يعني
بس لانه اكبر قوه شيعيه في العالم نهائي
ايران هي دوله لا تعترف باسرائيل فالجمعات
اللي هي ايران بتدعمها بتاخد نفسها زائد
التوجه
طيب اسمحوا لي انا برده علشان يكون في نوع
من التوازن ارجو ان ترجع وانا رجعنا
نحاولنا ارجع للديكور القديم الديكور ده
والله يعني الراجل المهندس اللي عمله
دلوقتي يمكن حزين جدا لان انتم قلتوا
الكلام ههه القسوه يعني الراجل بدل مجهود
وقال ان ده هيبقى برنامج كويس بس ههه
محتاج ممكن يعني همم مش عارف يعني كان
الله في عون والله من تعليقاتكم لكن هو
عموما ههه
بيضحك اصل هو الراجل كان فكرته انه عاوز
يعمل الاستديو زي اا يعني است- هو الي
هيفانا يعني فانتظرنا يفاجئنا في عامل
ستديو زي التليفزيون فلنور بس احنا مش
عاوزين تلفزيون هو الراجل طب ليه مش
عايزين تليفزيون
اول ما بدانا اول حلقه بالديكور الجديد
عرف ليه وعرف الناس يعني هجمته هجوم عنيفه
فبنرجع شويه شويه في كان همم
اسئله جايه من حضراتكم انا كنت وعدت
بالاجابه عليها هل هنشوف اوروبا بعيده عن
امريكا او منفصل عن توجهات القياده
الامريكيه
الاجابه السريعه انه
يعني النداء صعب انه يحصل على الاقل يعني
للسنوات القادمه انت عشان اوروبا تستقل عن
الولايات المتحده لازم يكون عندها
امكانيات الاستقلال دي قوه اقتصاديه كبيره
نعم ولكنها لا تتمتع بالقوه العسكريه
اللازمه حتى وان كان لدى فرنسا وردت طبعا
انا بتكلم على دول الاتحاد الاوروبي حتى
لو اضفت بريطانيا هذا لا يكفي السلاح
النووي لوحده ولا يكفي
روسيا عندها سلاح نووي لكن ده لا يكفي
لحسم المعارك مش كل واحد يعني هيكون عندي
مشكله معها استخدم السلاح النوويه هي في
حاجه كبيره جدا الى ما زالت الى الولايات
المتحده
خصوصا انه طبعا في حلقه كامله كده ممكن
ترجع لها بس همم يعني بعض الدول الاوروبيه
عاجزه عن الاستقلال زي الفولندا مثلا
وشايفه ان هي تعتبر الولايات المتحده على
ان تحتمي في المانيا هي عندها مشاكل عندها
مشاكل مع روسيا دول البلطيق مثلا الثلاث
عندها خوف من روسيا ما عندهاش في اندوق
الاوروبا تحميه فتفضل ان هي تقيم علاقت مع
الولايات المتحده دول طبعا بريطانيا
خيارها منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ان هي الولايات المتحده امريكا مستفيده
بان اوروبا تكون معتمده عليها وبالتالي له
سنوات طويله يعني هتفضل اوروبا عاجزه عن
الاستقلال او الانفصال اا عن الاستقلال
القرار عن الولايات المتحده ده كان سؤال
جاي على همم يعني حضرتكم بعثتوه على
الكوميونتي وعلى فيسبوك
في كان السؤال طبعا بتاع البكس احنا
جاوبناه بحلقه كامله في صديقنا بيقول مسلم
عقيل ما هو مستقبل الدول النفطيه وهل ممكن
مصادر الطاقه النظيفه تزيح النفط من
مكانته الحاليه في المستقبل القريب اي في
حدود ال 20 سنه شوف يا صديقي كل الابحاث
وكل الدراسات بتجمع على هذا كون انه في
طفره الان بالمناسبه بما فيها دراسات دول
الخليج انه النفط قدامه 15 20 سنه اشمعنا
15 20 سنه طبعا اي دراسه بتوصل لاي نتيجه
بتحط السيناريوهات
يحط السيناريو المعروض من النفط المخزون
اسعاره البدائل هتتوفر الاخرى باي سعر
في كم دوله الى اخره لكن
التوقف 15 20 سنه ده معناه الفتره اللي
بيقدر القائمين على الدراسه ان البدائل
هتكون متاحه اديكم مثال صغير العالم الان
قدر انه يولد الطاقه من الرياح ومن الشمس
وطبعا منال المياه
لو قدر يولدها باسعار ارخص وهو بيولدها
الوقت باسعارها خلاص ده واحد لو قدر بقى
يوصل للمعدله ديت قدرته على تخزين الطاقه
دي في بطاريات اكثر كفاءه لفتره طويله زي
البطاريات اللي هي في العربيات دي موجوده
لكنها
لم تتطور بالشكل اللي انت ممكن اييي مثلا
تولد الطاقه من الرياح بالليل وتبقى معاك
هي لمده ايام واسابيع دي لسه الوقت اللي
يتم فيه تخزين
القدره على تخزين الطاقه هتبقى نقطه
مفصليه التكنولوجيا بمعنى اصح المساله لما
الرهونه بالتكنولوجيا وتوليد الطاقه من
المصادر الثلاثه فالاجابه على قطعه عن
قولا واحدا ان البترول ولا غاز اخذ الى
همم
يعني لازم لازم يكون في بدائل اخرى
والبدائل بتتطور
بتجري كثير لكن انا يعني اهو
ما رايك
معلش لحظه طيب انا هاعمل كده لان هو
الاسئله بتجري قدامي بشكل سريع جدا
وتقريبا اخذ المؤامره لان انا شايفه
بيتعمر وبيتكلم في التليفون
اوكي
احنا عندنا اسئله كثيره
انا مش عاوز اثقل على الناس انا كمان 10
دقائق ونسيبهم علشان الناس ما تزهقش كامل
بس بتساله تتوقف عشان اعرف اقراها
اوك لحظه يا شباب
يعني لغايه ما تتوقف بس لا يعني اصل حكايه
اللاجئين دي او مش مساله حق او باطل طبعا
في قوانين دوليه بتنظم حقوق اللاجئين في
حقوق انسانيه بس الكلام ده كلام انشائي
في النهايه يعني في قانون في اعتبارات
انسانيه لكن في قدره للدوله على استقبال
لاجئين
المؤكد انه لبنان ولبنان مش قادر لانه هو
مش قادر ما فيش دوله مركزيه قويه تقدر
تقول اه او لا لكن اكيد ان في اتجاه كبير
في لبنان بيقول انا مش قادر احل مشاكلي
فمش اقدر احل كمان مشاكل السوريين تركيا
نفس القصه في اعتقاد مع الازمه لبنان
بالمناسبه تركيه بتعيش ازمه اقتصاديه
الغريبه ان في تماثل كبير بين الوضع
الاقتصادي في تركيا والوضع الاقتصادي في
مصر عندها ازمه اقتصاديه كبيره مش قليله
بس لاسباب يعني تتعلق بجهازها الاعلامي
بوجود عدد من اللي بيسموهم الاتراك العرب
ما بيتمش تسليط الضوء كفايه على الازمه
الاقتصاديه التركيه
بيعتقدوا اثناء الازمات دائما الناس
بيرموا باللوم على المهاجرين وهم عندهم
عدد مش قليله احنا بنتكلم على حوالي ثلاثه
ونصف ثلاثه وسبعه من 10 مليون سوري
وبالتالي في الغالب يعني هيكون فيه توجهه
انه يتم اعاده عدد كبير منهم خصوصا مع
خوفوط الصراع هناك في سوريا همم
وليه صديقه واخذانا ال ال
اوك شويه اوكي ماذا عن سيطره الحزب
الجمهوري في امريكا على مجلس الشيوخ
والنواب على السياسه العالميه ده سؤال بقى
هيكون مهم بس عاوز حلقه الحقيقه يعني يعني
في حاجات هيبقى فيها تغيرات كبيره وفي
حاجات مش هيكون فيها التغيرات تذكر لكن
المؤكد المؤكد اذا السيطره
دلوقتي بتقول ان الجمهوريين سيطروا على
مجلس الشيوخ لكن انه واقع على على النواب
لكن الشيوخ لسه المؤشرات مش واضحه هافترض
من سؤال حضرتك ان هم سيطروا على الاثنين
معناها انه السيد الرئيس سوف يصبح لمده
يعني بطه وما هي البطه العركات في السياسه
الامريكيه رئيس عاجز عنه ممارسه صلاحياته
كل ما يقول اه يقول له لا يقول لا يقولوا
له اه كذا وهتبقى
سيرك في الولايات المتحده
ايه استاذ سيد شو رايك في الفصائل
المقاومه في غزه
مش عارف اقول ايه سؤال صعب يعني بس يعني
من ناحيه الله فعلهم بعيشوا ظروف صعبه جدا
زي باقي الفلسطينيين في غزه ومن ناحيه
الثانيه انه
يعني
هم سياسيا مش قادرين يتوافقوا مع بعض
ويتوافقوا اصل انت حتى السؤال بتاعك دليل
على ماساه احنا بنتكلم على غزه طب ليه ما
بنتكلمش على فلسطين كلها ما بنتكلمش على
غزه ليه احنا سلمنا وهم بيقول لهم دور
كبير جدا على ان غزه دي حاجه متضفه دي
حاجه ثانيه يعني الفلسطينيين ما كانش
ناقصهم انه هم محتلين وفلسطين عندها ازمه
مع الكهان المحتل نيجي دلوقتي بنتكلم على
غزه وبنتكلم على الضفه هذه هي اكبر اخطاء
المقاومه يعني انه انت هنا في النهايه ان
احنا بنتكلم على غزه
اييه
هل تستطيع الدول الخليج حسب معركه اليمن
او لا تريد
هو هي لا تستطيع حاجه معركه اليابان يعني
عشان يكون الاجابه مش دبلوماسيه المساله
فوق طاقه السعوديه وفوق طاقه اليمن الى حد
كبير والا لحسن واحد وبرده يعني فكره
استقرار اليمن مصدرها بشكل كامل اصلا محل
خلاف بين دول الخليج لانه في صراع او في
الدول المستفيده من اليمن ما يبقاش دوله
مستقره وقويه لان ده هيهددهم بشكل كبير
ماذا تقدم الصين للعالم لو بدات الشركات
الغربيه بنقل مصانعها منها الى دول اخرى
كالهند ومصر وخصوصا ان الصين تعاني من
مشكله ديموغرافيه ضخمه وليس لا يديها
ثروات طبيعيه كروسيا مثلا ماذا تقدم الصين
للعالم لو بدات الشكل
هو يعني ال ال ال ال الكلام على الصين
اللي عامل زي كل الدول الكبيره بتتكلم عن
تقول مثلا الاولاد المتحده بتطهر بس
التطهر نسبي يعني كانت بعد الحرب العالميه
نصيبها من الناتج المحل الاجمالي حوالي
45% يعني العالم كله بينتج 55 وامريكا 45
لوحدها دلوقتي تتطهورت بقت حوالي 24 23 من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي يعني ما زالت قوه
عظمى واهم او اكبر اقتصاد في العالم الصين
بقيت دوله كبيره جدا قوه كبيره جدا عندها
تكنولوجيا حتى لو كانت التكنولوجات
الغربيه في بعض القطاعات متفوقه عليها
عندها
طبقه كبيره وسطى عندها قطع كبير متعلم
عندها عدد علماء هائل عندها براءه اخترعها
ان تقدم الكثير يعني ومع ذلك بالمناسبه
الكلام على الصين في الغرب هم اصلا
بيدرسوا الظاهره زي دراسه الفيل فاكر قصه
العميان الاربعه اللي كل واحد بيتلبس جزء
من الفيل على حسب يده ما بتقع عليه لانه
مش قادر يشوف الفيل كله فيصف الفيل ده رجل
لا ده همم ديل ده كذا كمان الغربه اصلا
محتاس فيه تفصيل في وضع الصين هل هي اخذها
في الصعود ده توجه وفي توجه في الولايات
المتحده ان هي وصلت لاقصى ما يمكن ان تصل
اليه وهي تنحدر المساله دي مش قادرين
يحسموها لانه قدرتهم على فهم ما يجري في
الصين غير مكتمل لكن قدر على سؤال حضرتك
الصين حتى لو لو تصبح قوه عظمى واصبح قوه
كبيره زي الهند لديها الكثير جدا لتقدمه
للعالم وصعب جدا ان تتخيل انه الغرب
يستخدم عنها بالكامل هيبيع لمين طيب ده
فيه سوء 1.4 همم يعني مليار و400 مليون
همم
مرحبا سيد لماذا يتعامل الرئيس الفرنسي مع
العالم وكانهم بسطاء يصدقون والله عندك حق
عزيز بيقول رئيس الفرنسي هو شخصيته كده
انا ما كنتش اعرف رئيس الفرنسي لما كان
وزير الاقتصاد ولا كان لي صديق همم فرنسي
يعني دائما كان يكلمني عنه هو راجل او
تستوكن بيتكلم كثير ويحب ينظر وهمم يعني
يعني كان اكيد كان اكاديمي شاطر جدا فيطلع
في الدول الافريقيه وفي الدول العربيه ادي
مناظرات ودي محاضرات وبيتعرض لمواقف محرجه
لانه يعني همم
عامل الناس كلهم على انهم تلاميذ وعاوزين
يتلقوا يعني
بس يا ريت كان عندنا من مكرونه ثلاثه
اربعه يعني ما هو مش رئيس بسيط يعني
اقصد في عالمنا هنا يعني ما رايك في الجيش
الالماني والياباني والتقدم في التسلح
قوي جدا ومهتم بقشره
قدراتهم حكوميه
ومبتسعاش ان هي تعود قوه نوويه ولا طبعا
امريكا ممكن تسمحلها كده لكن المانيا
اهمال الجيشها بشكل كبير جدا ودلوقتي
بتقول انا عاوز اطول الجيش والجيش ده اصل
هو مش مش سكني انا او قيمه العمدان يعني
هي عندها طبعا صناعات عسكريه كثيره
المساله هتحتاج كثير هتحتاج سنوات طويله
عشان يبقى عندها جيش قوي زي جيش اليابان
او جيش بقى زي الجيش الفرنسي او الجيش
البريطاني يعني
ايه
هل تسمحوا لي اخته
اخونا مصطفى
بيقول ما رايك في الاوضاع في العراق ارجو
من الاخوه لا من غير ما اعجبهم انا شفت
السؤال وهو من الاسئله اللي كان فيها عدد
كبير
العراق دلوقتي اخر التطورات في انه بقى في
رئيس دوله وفي رئيس وزراء
وبتكتمل الجهاز الاداري للدوله وده امر في
حربه منه العراق على مدار سنه اكثر شويه
من اكتوبر 2011
هذا تطور جيد لكنه مش مطمئن قوي لانه
الرئيس اولا ما عندوش حزب قوي يعني ما
عندوش قاعده هو اظن كان هو وحزمه فازوا
بثلاث مقاعد هو واحد منهم يعني معنى ذلك
ان هو له مقعدين اثنين القوه اللي اتت بك
اللي رئيس للحكومه رغم الاجماع ممن اعلم
من العراقيين انه راجل متفق على انه شخصيه
محترمه ورجل نزيه وكذا كل الكلام ده لكن
القوه الاساسيه اللي جاءت به هي الاحزاب
المحسوبه على ايران
والقوه التي سوف تكون عليها علامات
استفهام عليه هي القوه اللي تقدر تعتبرها
معادله لايران او معاديه على الاقل للاطار
التنسيقي يعني كله وبالتالي هل هو يقدر في
وضعه الهشه الضعيف ما عندوش قاعده
وعنده بس ما انت كمان اللي بيدعموك جاؤوا
بك الى السلطه او دعموك مع عوافر الاحترام
ليه عندهم طالب ديت تعيينات في وزارات
تصورات لاشنتات داخليه وخارجيه اذا كان
عندك انت اثنين بس قاعدتك السياسيه اثنين
في البرلمان هل تقدر تقاوم ضغطهم طب هل
تستطيع ان ترضي ال- الصدر وكل القوى
المتحالفه معه من الكورد السنه الى اخره
تستطيع هل تستطيع يكون موقفك ايه من الدول
الخليجيه والدول العربيه هل تستطيع ان
تتقرب منها وفي نفس الوقت لا تغضب ايران
همم ايه هو موقفك من ال- ال- ال-
يعني المواقف الغربيه والولايات المتحده
يعني اللي بتاخذ من العراق زي ايران ال-
اا البلد اا سحل الصراع يعني احنا قدام
لحظه هدوء نسبي يمكن لان الناس
بتلتقط انفاسها لكن يؤسفني واتمنى ان يخيب
الله ظني انه همم النساء لم تستقر بهذا
الوضع يعني
همم
اخونا محمد راز كان بيسال هل الاداره
المصريه الحاليه كانت على الطريق الصحيح
من بدايه من من البدايه في الاصلاح
الاقتصادي ام انها اخطات التقدير
كمثالها كانت لابد من ان تهتم بالتصنيع عن
البنيه التحتيه
هي الحكومه قالت انا اصلا يعني العمليه مش
عاوزه الحكومه بتقول ان هي عملت امور
سليمه واخطاء في امور
فهذا لم يعد سرا همم انما بتقول لي انه هل
الحكومه من البدايه في الاصلاح الاقتصاد
الحكومه لم تبدا الاصلاح الاقتصادي بالشكل
اللي هو في الكتب يعني اللي بتعمله مصر
وبتعمله حكومات اخرى ان هي عملت عمليه
اصلاح مالي ونقيطي يعني
استعدادا تمهيدا لاصلاح اقتصادي اللي هو
عنيف جدا ان انت تصلح النظام ده تصلح لنا
التعليم تصلح نظام الجمارك تصلح النظام
التامين الصحي همم يعني تصلح نظام التقاضي
تصالح نظام تن الاحكام دي امور بطبيعتها
بتاخذ وقت طويل وهي مهمه صعبه وحتى هذه
اللحظه الجهد اللي بدل من جانب الحكومه
المصريه كان في السيطره على ما هي اصل هي
عمليه صعبه انت ما فيش حل ابدا ابدا
لمصر او لا غير مصر الا ان يكون عندها
قادر على الانتاج ده كلام يبدو سهل جدا
على ارض الواقع بتقابله عقبات خارجيه
وداخليه اولا اول عقبه وضوح الرؤيه هل
صانع القرار رؤيه واضح ان لابد من تشجيع
الانتاج دي نقطه لما هو لو هو عنده وضوح
الرؤيه ده
بتقابلك اول حاجه التحديات الداخليه جمعات
المصالح وجماعات المصالح مش موجوده في
امريكا بس موجوده في كل دوله
وطبعا الضغوط الخارجيه لكن عموما انا
هاستاذنك ان احنا ده سؤال يتطلع على نعرف
اقتصاد ونتكلم عن الاقتصاد المصري مره
ثانيه حاضر
انا مش عارف اقرا الاسئله يا حمو انا هاخذ
لغات الساعه 9:30 بس ساعدني في وقف
الاسئله لانه مش عارف لانها كثيره ولا انا
في حاجه يعني هي لا تتوقف
هي فعلا كثيره
جدا يعني يعني اشكر الناس ولا اعمل ايه
انا مش عاوز اكون اثقلت اكثر من كده عليهم
هل تاذنولي
الساعه 9:30 اتوقف وكل من سال سؤال والله
ان شاء الله يعني مخلصا انا هاحاول عليه
في حلقات اللي هي همم
الاسئله اللي بتحتاج الى حلقات او ان شاء
الله نزود عدد المرات اللي ممكن نلتقي
فيها مباشره همم بس توقف الاسئله وانا
تقدر توقف الدردشه لا مش مش عاوز اوقف
الدردشه حد بيقول الحل اللي انت توقف ده
لا ما انا يعني تبقى مش حاجه لطيفه يعني
لكن حاضر
ما رايك في سعود صادرات المغرب ما ده برده
من الامور الجيده المغرب عندها وضع
اقتصادي جيد بالنسبه لطول اخرى في يعني
الدول العالم العربي وعندها صناعه سيارات
مزدهره وعندها تجربه ناجحه في القصه ديت
وده من الموضوعات اللي انا كنت بقول
لحضراتكم في اول الحلقه النهائيه ان شاء
الله هتكون مطروح الاقتصاد المغربي همم في
حلقه على اقتصاد نعرف باذن الله
بالمناسبه وحضراتكم عارفين اصل انا ما
اعرفش اذا كان احنا عملنا قناه انا عارف
انه طبعا انا قلت وعملت برومو احنا عملنا
نعرف اقتصاد علشان تتناول القضايا
الاقتصاديه بس فاللي ممكن مهتم باقتصاد
هيدور بس على نعرف اقتصاد هيلاقيها ولو مش
عارفين توصلوا لها زي بعض بيسالني يقول لي
وانا ابعث له الرابط يعني
في الديسكريبشن برده في الوصف الناس تقدر
وهحط همم رابط
اقتصاد اا نعرف اقتصاد في الدسكربشن في
الحلقات اللي هي في اللي هي بالضبط كده
هل سيواجه محمد بن سلمان معارضه همم
معرضه داخل الاسره الحاكمه بعد وفاه والده
انا اقدر ادي اجابه عامه لان ده عاوز احد
يكون عارف داخل يعني ده خائن الاسره
السعوديه واقدر اقول لك انه انا سمعت
بالمسؤولين امريكان كبير رغم ان هم يعني
يعني بالغين النفوذ في دول كثيره ومنها
السعوديه بيقولوا احنا مبنعرفش امور كثيره
مناعجز عن معرفتها ولكن ما فيش انتقال
ثالث للسلطه
ده حتى احيانا في الدول المتقدمه يعني
انما في الدول المتقدمه زي ما شفنا كده في
امريكا امريكا يعني كانت حلقه لكن بتحصل
برده في دول ثانيه يعني الانتقال الثالث
للسلطه ده في الدوله ناميه حاجه نادره
وبالتالي دائما بيكون
الانتقال خشبي يعني
مستقبل الانقلاب في السودان وهل ممكن يخرج
الاقتصاد من وحدته الى اتت الثوره بحكومه
بدنيه رشيده شوف انا ممكن اتكلم على الجزء
الثاني اللي هو حل الاقتصاد ممكن السوداني
انا بقول ليه بعلق على الجزء الاولاني ده
هياخذنا في قصه ثانيه ما هو
يعني
انت بتقول عليه انقلاب يبقى تجرنا لمين هو
اللي منقلب على مين والقوه لانه الجيش
بيقول لك طب تعالوا خذوا شكله حكومه فده
قصه جدليه يعني انما بتتكلم على الاقتصاد
السوداني الاقتصاد السوداني لو استقرت
الاوضاع النهارده لو استقرت الاوضاع
النهارده هيحتاج مش اقل من يعني 40 50 سنه
علشان يكون اقتصاد متعافي ممكن ده يكون
كلام متشائم بس اقصد اقول علشان يبقى زي
الاقتصاد المصري زي الاقتصاد المغربي لانه
هيواجه تحديات هائله الشيء الجيد جدا عند
السودانيين ان عندهم امكانيات ضخمه جدا
ربنا اداهم ارض زراعيه اداهم المياه اداهم
موارد طبيعيه جيده اداهم كفاءات بتشتغل في
الخارج ده جيد انما للاسف دوله برده
مساحتها كبيره في رغبات كبيره للانفصال ما
فيش رغبه دوليه كبيره في ان هي تساعدهم
يعني
وبالتالي السودان اقتصاده يعني هيعاني
لفتره طويله جدا جدا للاسف الشديد يعني
رد على سؤالك اذا جاءت حكومه رشيده مدنيه
رشيده او حتى حكومه عسكريه رشيده
بس طبعا افضل كثير لو يكون مدنيه لكن
دائما مشكله تحقق في دول كثيره اكيد هيحصل
تطور كبير ممكن السودانيين يشهدوا اثاره
همم تحسن على مدار سنتين ثلاثه وخلال
السنوات يبقى بيت باي بيت او يعني شويه
شويه تبقى الامور جيده
ايه
هو ممكن استاذ سيد لو ممكن تعمل بريد
الكتروني للاسئله والاستفسارات كما يفعل
نعومه شمس جدا ده يعني
نعمل بس احنا عاملين والله
لو تلقى هذا القدر من الاسئله ما اعرفش
الراجل المعجزه والله ما شاء الله راجل
عدى التسعين لكن هو شخصيه استثنائيه بعقله
ما شاء الله بالقهوه ربنا يدي له الصحه
والعافيه وعنده نزاهه اخلاقيه تحسد عليها
مجرد ان يعني تحط اسمي في عباره في هذا
الرجل يعني ده شكرا عظيم يعني يعني شيء
مبهج
هل ممكن تتجه السعوديه والامارات الى
الصين وروسيا وتستبدل امريكا كحاليف بسبب
الغطرسه والتعامل السيئه من امريكا
الاجابه
يمكن ان تتجه السعوديه والامارات ودول
الخليجيه الى الصين لكن لا تستبدلها
بامريكا يعمل ايه بتبقى تلقائيا على فكره
الجغرافيا بتلعب دور يعني الاجابه على
سؤالك علشان ما اكونش خرجت انه هي خلاص
تبادل التجاري بين الدول الخليج والصين
اكبر بكثير من التبادل التجاري ما بين دول
الخليج والولايات المتحده طب اذا كانت
مصالح التجاريه مع الصين وبتنسي يوم بعد
يوم ايه اللي يخليني اسيب الصين هتبقى فيه
خطوات دراميه اكثر واكثر لكن هذا يعني
التخلي عن الولايات المتحده لانها قوه
كبيره وحتى لو تراجعت عن مركز الوضع
الاستثناء اللي هي فيه وهي بتراجع هتظل
قوه كبيره همم وبالتالي ده يعني كنت باقول
لك ان الجغرافيا بتلعب دور يعني مثلا
بدايه التحالف من الاربعينات ويعني مرورا
حتى سنوات قليله كانت الولايات المتحده
واللي هي اكبر مستهلك للطاقه في العالم ما
عندهاش طاقه تكفيها خصوصا من البترول
والغاز فكانت دول الخليج مهمه جدا لها ولو
حلفائها طبعا جاءت في فتره كانت تكساس
ولايات اخرى فيها طفره ثم انخفضت
ضعفت
احتياطات الولايات المتحده في بدايه
السبعينات وعلشان كده الحاضر اللي طبقته
الدول العربيه سنه 73 كان مؤثر جدا على
امريكا
الجغرافيا لعبه دور بتلعب دور في ان
العلاقه تبقى قويه ان امريكا محتاجاهم
محتاجه دول الخليج والدول النفطيه دلوقتي
الجغرافيا لعبه دور ثاني والتكنولوجيا
بالدور الجغرافيا بتقول انه الصين
والهند دول تحتاج الى طاقه ومعداش ما هياش
غنيه بالطاقه ودول الخليج يعني بتبحث عن
من يصدر لاعب ودول الخليج بتبحث عن من
تصدر له وفي نفس الوقت التكنولوجيا
الامريكيه خالتها تقريبا مكتفيه تاتيا من
الطاقه وبالتالي في تطورات تكنولوجيا
وجغرافيا بتدفع دول الخليج الى الدول اللي
هي ممكن تتعاون معها بشكل اكثر همم كفاءه
ااا
اي فريق تشجع في كاس العالم
والله سؤال حلو
انا بحب الكره جدا بس ما فيش فريق باشجع
في كاس العالم يعني ايه انا هاستمتع
بالمشاهده زي زي حضرتك كده بس يعني انا
انا بشجع ليفربول طبعا اذا ما كانش يعني
بشجع مانشستر يونايتد مانشستر سيتي لو
ليفربول ما بيلعبش علشان انا من عشاق محمد
صلاح
همم ارجو الرد همم سيد لو سمحت تعبت من
الكوبي ايه هو ايه سؤال حضرتك حاضر
تعيش فيها ظروف تعيسه جدا جدا جدا
لا يستطيع انه يحقق الحد الادنى من رفاهيه
شعب ما فكان الله في عون هذا الشعب يعني
سلام عليكم اسناد ايراني احبكم من طهران
متابع من اهلا وسهلا بحضرتك الى اين يتجه
لوضع في سوريا اجابنا على هذا السؤال وسوف
نجيب عنهم مره اخرى هل تستطيع مصر ان تجبر
اوروبا على دفع صادراتها من الغاز بالجنيه
هتستفيد ايه ده احنا اصلا عندنا
جنيه ما احنا ممكن نطبعه لا يعني التصور
بعد اذن حضرتك محتاج ان انت تصلح هذا
المفهوم روسيا دي قوه كبرى وعندها
اعتبارات سياسيه مصر دوله اقليميه ما
عندهاش لان نفود ولا الثروات الروسيه وهي
محتاجه تقنع الناس يشتروا بترولها وغزها
بالدولار وباليور عشان تاخذوا وتستورد
روسيا تستطيع الاستغناء الى حد كبير عن
الغرب عندها علماء وعندها شركائها وعندها
علاقتها بالصين انما مصر
ما عندهاش القدره دي محتاجه تستورد
مستلزمات الانتاج محتاجه تستورد الغداء
وبحتاج ايه محتاجه الدولار واليوم مش
محتاجه مزيد من الجنيه اللي ممكن يطبعوه
في مطابعهم
السؤال الاخير اللي في تقرير للبنك الدولي
2010 وصل لجدي بي في ايران الى 1.7
تريليون رغم الحصار الاقتصادي وانخفاض
الجديد في
انخفاض الجدي به في تركيا رغم ان كل
البلديه الذي انا ما اعرفش دقه الرقم ده
1.7 اعتقد ده رقم كبير جدا ل- اا يعني رقم
كبير اشك فيه لكن ممكن يكون اللي انت
قريته بيحسبه بطريقه ثانيه
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لدوله باستخدام
وعادل القوه الشرعيه يعني مثلا مصر الناتج
المحل الاجمالي لها حوالي 450 مليار دولار
ده كده بدولار قصاد الدولار يعني يعني
حوله الجنيه المصري للدولار حط لها حوالي
450 ده اسمه نومينال القيمه الاسميه في
واحد يقول لك ايه بس الدولار في مصر
قدرته على الشرع او الجنيه في مصر بيشتري
اكثر من اللي بيشتريه الدولار في امريكا
يعني انت ممكن مثلا تاخذ تاكسي من القاهره
لاسكندريه سي مثلا ب 300 جنيه مثلا يعني
انما ال300 جنيه دول اا
عشان تاخذ المسافه دي في امريكا هتدفع
اكثر بكثير جدا الخلاصه انه بيستخدم معيار
اسمه معادله القوه الشرائيه فيقول لك ال
450 دولار دي قدرتها في مصر تعادل مثلا
900 همم مليار دولار
وبالتالي اشك في هذا الرقم في استاذنك
راجع وانا راجع برده لكن عموما السؤال
بصفه عامه ما ده اللي انا كنت باقول عليه
انه ايران
بقطع النظر عن موقفك السياسي منها هي دوله
قدرت ااا يعني تدير امورها تحت الحصار
وقدرت تطور صناعات كثيره من الناحيه ديت
تستحق الاعجاب
[موسيقى]
انا اسف انا هضطر اتوقف لانه احنا بقى لنا
ساعه ونص وانا مليت يعني مش عاوز حضرتكم
تملوا همم لكن همم
لوبي الموضه في مصر لوبيا الموضه
يعني بيسال عن تاثيره يعني
عموما انت هو التعبير المناسب انا مع كلمه
لوبي ممكن تبقى مبالغ فيها جدا انه اللوبي
ده معناه يا جماعه الضغط بتمارس نفوذ على
السلطه علشان تحصل على انما ممكن تتكلم
بقى انه ما هو في يعني مثلا اطباء التخسيس
مثلا صناعه التخسيس ديت بتضغط علشان
حضرتك
قل انه في جماعه بتدفع لمصالحها ويحاول
انه يغير كل سنه مثلا
الموضه علشان يعمل مبيعات اكثر يعني ما
تقدرش تعتبره رد بس الرد
تعبير اللوبي الموضه من لسان نائب وزير
الاعلام السابق وماله اهو
تعبير لوبي معلش ده هو تعبير مبالغ اه لا
يعني حد بيقول لوبي زي ما لوبي اطباء
التخسيس زي لوبي مثلا همم
[موسيقى]
اي جماعه ذات مصالح يعني لكن كلمه لوبي
تعبير مبالغ فيه جدا وبعدين ما تنساش انه
تعبير له مصر بلد بنتكلم 110 مليون و450
مليار دولار يعني بلد دخلوا بسيط معلش عدد
الناس اللي هم مهتمين بالموضه واللي ممكن
ياثر فيه لوبي الموضه او حتى في باريس ايه
له بالموضه يعني ولكن الناس بيدفعه دافع
عن الناس لمزيد من الاستهلاك وبالتالي
طبعا دي جماعه موجوده في كل الصناعات يعني
ايه انا غسيل الشكر والله انا عارف ان في
عدد ضخم جدا من الاسئله
سامحوني علشان يعني اكرر اعتذاري انا شاكر
الاهتمامكم جدا بس اوعدكم والله ان
الاسئله دي سوف اتابعها مره اخرى نعمل لها
فلتره باذن الله ونجاوب اكبر عدد منها
واستاذنكم اذا كنتم تعتقدوا ان هذا النوع
المفتوح من الدردشه مفيد لكم اكتبوا لي
وقولوا لي تحب نلتقي اسبوعيا انا جاهز كل
اسبوعين انا جاهز كل شهر انا جاهز مره
ثانيه سوف اراجع هذه الاسئله والموجبها في
حلقات اخرى باذن الله شكرا جزيلا وربنا
يسعد